AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME, D'OH, NO, THE
DIDN'T.
>> Chris: GREAT NEWS, DUFF
DRINKERS, SHORTS EATERS AND HANK
AZARIA'S AGENT, FOX JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT THE SIMPSONS HAS
BEEN RENEWED FOR TWO MORE
SEASONS, TAKING IT THROUGH
SEASON 28.
AND MAKING IT OLDER THAN THE
HIPSTERS THAT QUOTE IT IN THEIR
TINDER PROFILES.
THE CITIZENS OF SPRINGFIELD
HAVE BEEN THROUGH A LOT IN MORE
THAN TWO DECADES BUT THERE'S NO
WAY THEY'VE TACKLED EVERYTHING.
I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME A SIMPSONS
PLOT LINE THAT IN 26 SEASONS
HASN'T BEEN DONE.
60-SECONDS ON THE CLOCK.
BEGIN.
EUGENE.
>> THEY INTRODUCE THEIR NEW SEXY
SON DARNELL SIMPSON, AND HE
HAS A CATCHPRAHSE OF "OH, HELL,
D'OH."
>> Chris: POINTS.
MATT.
>> SIMPSONS REUNITE WITH
THEIR LONG LOST BROTHER OJ.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JON.
>> MR. BURNS ORDERS A DRONE
STRIKE ON SHELBYVILLE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MATT.
>> LISA GETS AN ABORTION.
>> Chris: TECHNICALLY SHE WOULD
BE LIKE 36 BY NOW.
>> YES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JON.
>> MARGE SHOWS HER TITS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YOU SAID THAT A LITTLE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY -- MATT.
>> YEAH.
>> Chris: JUST LIKE BIG HONKING
YELLOW TITS.
MATT.
>> THE SIMPSONS FINALLY REALIZE
THEY ARE MADE OUT OF BUTTER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
EUGENE.
>> MARGE DIES.
>> Chris: NO!
OH, NO POINTS FROM THE AUDIENCE
ON THAT ONE.
JON.
>> HOMER SHOWS HIS DICK.
>> Chris: I AM A LITTLE
WORRIED ABOUT YOU SOMETIMES.
BUT POINTS.
JON.
>> BARNEY KILLS MILHOUSE IN A
DRUNK DRIVING ACCIDENT.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MATT.
>> TRACY ULLMAN WAKES UP AND
REALIZES IT WAS ALL A DREAM.
>> Chris: YES! AMAZING. POINTS.